the left-hander john lester john throws
a good 14 basketball cutter combination
we'll mix in some change ups as well
last time he threw a couple curveballs
more he fists like around 70 miles an
hour to keep the guys off balance one
another count to rosarine in the pitch
here's a swing and a lie drive into
center field and it's going to hang up
there and be caught by para margot is
going to tag from third to throw is
halfway toward the dugout it's not even
close
as margot will score and just like that
two batters in
the rays of a one nothing lead over the
nationals oh you love it
going the other way
stolen base force the air score on the
shallow sac fly rosarina gets that ball
out there off the end of the bat but
deep enough margot with good speed early
lead so a run already in the book one
nothing raised here in the top of the
first full count to yandy diaz
and he swings and hits one deep to left
that baby is really out of
here deep into the seats and left and
for a moment
we thought it might
wind up on the walkway out there
he really
got into that one
and the rays have a two-nothing lead
drew rasmussen will start this thing off
for the raise as the opener be careful
with this guy please you know the book
on schwarber like a lot of lefties
elevating you'll get it by him but
he has been ready for that pitch the 3-2
pitch
and they got him how about that well 99
set that up
and
a strikeout and schwarber you've
accomplished something the way he's been
hitting the ball out well rasmussen can
do that that was an 86 mile an hour
slider and it's a good enough pitch that
you can start it out over the heart of
the plate turner's tied for the league
leading steal 16 and 19 tries
trey turner over the glove of mike russo
and it's a good thing for the raise
girmeyer was playing over toward the gap
that had enough juice on it to get to
the scoreboard
but he was able to cut it off and trey
turner is marched toward 100 hits
continues one out josh bell coming up
and now the set runners go first pitch
high and juggle by zunino no throw he'll
throw it right back to the pitcher it's
a double steal led by turner
now the national league leader with 18
stolen bases and the trail runner soto
gets his fourth of the year and with
that they take away a double play
possibility looks like the rays are
gonna bring the infield on the left side
which makes no sense in a two-nothing
game and the count is two and one early
in the game infield in
bell up the middle for a base hit
turner
here comes soda and just like that the
nets tie this game we are loving these
first innings whether it's power or
basins meantime ray's trying to break
this time two and one the stretch
and there's one down the left field line
again is that ball going to be fair
that ball is a fair ball and gone home
run for zanino
on a 2-1 pitch
right down the line and the rays are
again up by two it's a 4-2 ball game
sheriff deals to schwarber
got him
3-1 fastball that got away from the
left-hander and schwarber is aboard with
one out appeared to have gotten him in
the left hand there rather the wrist
hopefully he's okay not much muscle or
padding in that area yeah there's nobody
in baseball that wants to see that
happen turner versus sheriff
and this time he's going to pull it
extra bases schwarber coming to third
bob henley's going to hold him
to return her into second
and with juan soto coming up
the nats have the tying run at second
base so we have a lefty lefty matchup
juan soto hold for one career against
ryan sheriff runners lead second and
third the 1-1 pitch
soto left side
there's a ground ball that gets through
they'll hold the second runner trey
turner because a rosarito got to it
and juan soto grounds his way to rbi
number 35. well just as he said bob
played to his advantage so the nats have
the line moving here with the tying run
at third base still only one out and now
josh bell
pace on a no two pitch the nets have
answered again and it's a four four ball
game so ryan sheriff has faced five
batters and the only man he retired was
john western i felt like josh bell
hasn't had a right-handed bat in quite
some time and this is a great piece of
hitting on a tough slider
two strikes
keeps his head on it
greeted by a base hit now they're loaded
up for starlin castro
so there's no second baseman there and
that's where castro hits it here comes
bell he follows soto home and the
nationals lead
6-4 well the raise analytics have not
been monitoring stalin castro's
propensity to go to right field recently
he's been doing a really good job of
letting the ball travel
rosarina with a count of one and one
that's a shot into right field that's
going to go all the way to the wall
rosso scores to make it a one-run game
and into second goes to rosarina it's
6-5 now well that breaking ball great
job by a rose arena to sit back trey
with another multi-hit effort today and
trey turner right now has 98 hits
that ball hit well
right center he's got 99 hits
c
u later happy birthday trey
and guess what he needs for the cycle
something he's very capable of doing
more on that later the nets have a
two-run lead get this guy
to denver somebody took his ticket he
needs to be there mercer's been to the
plate twice in this game struck out both
times
oh that ball's well hit to left mercer
see
you
later his first rbi as a national and
what a way to do it that's jordy
mercer's
65th career home run
and his 300th career rbi perfect how
about that for symmetry now eight five
the raised down by three
there's a swing and a miss
so lester is out on strikes so with two
outs a run in on the home run
kyle schwarber
there's a strike called on the outside
corner 96. it's a nice pitch against
schwaber who's 0 for three turner is the
all-time nationals leader in triples but
he has just won this year he's due for a
triples binge
turner right field line and it's beyond
the reach of margaux he's going to
second he's going to third here's the
throw
set goal for trey turner
on his birthday come on out of the box
he had triple on his mind he was flying
around the bases
check him out
elevated cutter and he had that on his
mind the entire way he did not pick up
bob henley once he said i'm getting this
three bagger they say the triples the
hardest one to get but they're not trey
turner three is the major league record
basic trick and walk home
and one soto has another rbi
the nationals lead nine to five
soto walking to his lead at third waka
to castro
castro high in the year deep right
center
c
u
later his first home run in six weeks
and a monster blast the nets are up 11-5
three balls two strikes and now the
pitch
jon gomes with a fantastic ap
12 on the board for the next as josh
bell comes home two hits and a walk by
the nets catcher who refuses to look
tired one and one on harrison here's the
pitch to harrison driven to the air to
deep right margot going back still back
way back this one is off the wall
caravan past them fielded by kiermeier
two runs will score combs across the
plate here comes castro in the score
and gomes holding it third and it's
second with a two run booming double off
the right field wall is josh harrison
it's now the nationals 14 in the range
five
one ball two strikes to count
row blaze to right it'll back up marco
just a bit tagging is mercer and then
actually 15 to five
[Applause]
disappointing afternoon and evening
there's a shot into center field for a
base hit or goal will score and the rays
score their sixth run of the game trying
to win their fourth in a row overall and
trying to make it 14 out of 17.
o2
left side
castro
one more throw close game over and bang
zuma curly w's in the books